almost six months ago we were
in equal we went in an activity and then
that activity brought with it all
this mobilization because we were attacked
by forces of order there in Mexico
policemen by federals by military in
they were all attacking us that
night
today I am here
for
invite the people of the USA where we
continue to support and that mainly that
help us press the government of
this country that in turn this
press Mexico so it does not close the
case then of the 43
I had to sing
wake up from your quiet sweet sleep
the rose color wake up because to your
around maybe they do not see it here
in this country or probably if
simply that blind eyes are made